one of our favorite humans on the planet
and favorite guests
fresh off of a 100 yard performance
including a touchdown not only for the
san francisco 49ers but for my fantasy
team
uh the aroma of the comeback nice
put me in position to win this week he's
my buddy george kittle how are you
george
rich happy to be back what an intro man
you drafted me in fantasy
big time george big time what round
well i mean first of all you oh whoa
right to it well first of all here
what round um third
i think i'm okay with that ten team
league ten team league you're one of the
top 30.
tom you know top 30. um oh absolutely
um and i and just so you understand this
and uh i will say the other uh
opposite when kelsey calls in i took you
in front of kelsey
i like that now hold on a second george
uh i'm i'm not only a fan of yours but a
fan of deons did you do a dion did you
do a dion sanders going into the end
zone last night
we were in the throwbacks got to pay a
little respect
that's what you did last night right you
you put your hand behind your helmet
and you also held the ball in a certain
way to go back and forth right as you
went into the end zone
just had a little bit of fun man i love
it
look i said it's something about those
all white throwbacks man they just get
you all excited
that is an oh i i didn't you know what i
didn't even put the two and two together
but now that's why i'm glad i have you
on the show
um and it looked like a lot was being
put together last night george did you
get the sense that this is okay that
this is what um this offense looked like
somewhat uh similar to last year did you
get that sense because it passed that
eye test for me watching from home
last year yeah i mean i think there's
still a lot of mistakes for us to
correct but our overall
confidence as an offensive unit like
playing together 11 guys you know
working towards the same goal
you could see that you could sense it on
the field and that was i will say that
was like the first time this season
other than maybe a couple drives in a
game or two
uh this season i've been a part of but
like the whole game felt like we were
playing well we were controlling the
line
of scrimmage and we weren't hurting
ourselves we were just making play after
play after play to be consistent and
stay in front of the change
in front of the chains and then when you
do that you just get confidence and i
think that's what we had last night
and then debo just running downhill like
last year too
maybe that's got a somewhat something to
do with it as well he is just
yeah that's not bad either i guess you
know it's crazy like before last week
the dude he had three practices since
the super bowl because he hurt his foot
right so yeah it's his second week back
i assume there'd be a little bit of rest
versus miami but
i think uh i think he's feeling like his
old self again and he's
just running around like a bowling ball
which is pretty fun to see most dirt as
well
i mean he you you he and debo
all just three just off the top my head
you guys just you arrive
with intent do you discuss this is that
part of the plan
to arrive with intent all of you george
well i think um something that we
figured out is when when you hit them
before they hit you it hurts less
i love that yeah and so when you give
them the impact
right and then you probably don't get
hit by four guys you only get hit by
that one guy and then you hit the ground
and so
that's one thing i always try to do that
and i know uh debo's run style has
definitely evolved
as well as mine um and then rahim just
is
so fast and he gets to 23 miles per hour
in two steps which is not fair
um it's just that's really fun to watch
by itself george kittle here on the rich
eisen show your quarterback is much
maligned sir there's no other way to put
it
um from uh from
many quarters uh in this football planet
and
um his performance and then his removal
from the game
last week against miami only ignited all
that what
what is he like uh in a week with
everybody talking about this
um like in practice this past week walk
me through what jimmy g is like to be
around
george he's the exact same guy every
single day
he has been since he got here from if he
has three touchdowns 250 300 yards in
sunday night football
or if he got benched he's the same guy
you know whenever he comes in on monday
morning
and uh he leads the same way and that's
why we love jimmy because he's always
consistent he's always himself he's
always professional
and he always holds himself to a high
standard so that consistency is you know
what a team like us needs we have a lot
of young guys playing and
when guys see that and guys see that you
can take coaching you can still bounce
back and play at a high level
that's where our team elevates because
we have leaders like jim
uh that allow us to be great now i i i
don't ask that
like uh to try and i guess justify
the media right i don't ask that because
that's that's like an old saw
also in super bowl weeks where we talk
about a distraction
uh to all the players uh and it just
feeds itself by saying this is a
distraction so let's talk about a
distraction
while we're all waiting for for a game
to start like i i legitimately ask this
because
i hear rumors i hear whispers i hear
sorts of conversations that
that jimmy g might not be the the guy
for years to come uh despite his
contract
and and that's why i ask it to see like
do you hear that and just kind of
look at jimmy when he comes in and see
how he reacts or this is
really not even on the radar screen for
you guys seriously i mean in the locker
room i don't think it's on the radar at
all
i i we come to work jimmy g is our qb
he's our leader
um you know we rallied behind him i mean
i think that's why he plays so well it's
because he got a team that supports in
the way that we do
that's just where we are every single
day in the locker room but i mean i i
don't hear anything all i know is that
jimmy g is my qb and
he's going to win us a lot of games dude
has he had to lose back-to-back games in
the nfl which i think is pretty
that's a pretty good record too yeah
that is a that is amazing
george uh i mean to what do you i guess
you can attribute that to
the personality that you just mentioned
right
yeah no i he everything that jimmy g
gets he he works for like there's
nothing he doesn't
like he's not i'd say like the most
talented qb in the nfl but the amount of
work ethic that he puts in everything
makes him a great qb
i mean he has the intangibles but
because of his work ethic he gets way
better
and that that's what makes us better
because you know we have a lot of guys
that we're all good football players but
the way that we work and the way we come
to work every single day is what makes
us great
and that's what our whole team is uh
made up of well i guess i'm also giving
you a preview since
you're playing the patriots this week i
mean that's only gonna be a new baby
you know i'm excited that's only going
to be that's only going to be the
half the conversation leading up all
week which i've been i've been waiting a
while to say on to new england
i've been waiting a while to say that is
that right
yeah it's my first time getting to play
them you know that's it's so uh yeah i'm
just
i'm excited for this week never played
in boston i have a couple buddies that
played for them so
it's going to be a fun one okay uh and
uh a few minutes left here with uh
george kittle uh on the rich eisen show
um so when i saw you in uh
in uh in indianapolis i tweeted this out
at you too
uh the night that your buddy uh big
bobby tonyan went off
for the packers you brought him he's a
buddy of yours
you worked out with him throughout the
uh off season non-playing season
you you told me uh when he was standing
there in indy when you were kind enough
to be part of run rich run you're like
keep an eye out for this guy
um he seems to be really settling into
his own
in green bay wouldn't you say george oh
british i can't talk enough about big
bobby
um he's he's a great friend of mine um
we have the same agent trained together
at the combine have been you know
friends since
that whole process trained with me the
last couple years in nashville
um just really close friend of mine in
this
seeing his work ethic and how he attacks
everything and then finally being able
you know to get the opportunity to go
out there and perform you know monday
night football score three touchdowns
i i was you know incredibly happy it was
actually it was funny
i was at a wedding my teammate trent
taylor got married that monday night
um just a little ceremony uh out in
california
just us four really but bobby had that
had the three touchdowns and i was given
you know i'm
trying to play by play during his
wedding hey rob just scored another
touchdown because we're all friends and
kind of highlighted the night and uh i
feel bad for trent but
hey look if if anybody's gonna steal any
thunder on a wedding night i mean that's
not a bad way to do it uh no it's not at
all man
but it's it's just neat to see hard work
pay off like that man you know
because you were telling me all about
him and and i'm like keep an eye out and
then he
he's just beginning to to bust out um in
green bay and that's
you know i know you like talking about
your friend i forget i give you the
floor on that front
i do no i i can talk about my buddies
all day no i'm sure
and so uh one thing about you george i
know you got you got a lot of journey to
get to
but um you now have had 10 100 yard
receiving games
um in your career that is most by a
tight end
since 1950 when you hear a stat like
that you you think what george
well i got to get some more i guess
okay that's simple just try to keep
going um
that's the thing about football you know
it's kind of uh you know what are you
doing for me lately and you know i love
you know having great games and stuff
but i look at it and i'm like hey that's
really cool and
i'll look back on that when i'm done
playing football so i'm just going to
try to continue to add to those
um see if i can just get better every
single day okay
uh and before i let you go i know you
need to run um
i don't i i know i know you do um pun
intended no no i know
i've been told you need to lift george
oh yeah that's on my list uh it starts a
little bit i'm good man no no i i don't
want to tell him i'm at the ridge no no
i appreciate that george
i'm sure kyle uh coach shanahan won't
have a problem with that at all
um i i noticed our alma maters don't
play each other this year
did you notice that there's no iowa
michigan game to talk i know michigan
uh called and they said we don't want to
play you guys don't ruin our chances of
getting to the playoffs
even though they don't really have a
chance anyways oh my gosh
well do you at least take on ohio state
do you at least play them so you can i
think we do at the end
you know i will say this yes uh michigan
has a better chance of nebraska so
no worries i will take that
um i will take that um and hope that
you're
you're correct what does a lift look
like tell me a george kittle lift walk
me through a lift
oh we got uh we had a big front squat
day today rich i'm going for like 335
for speed
no what now um okay con just
imagine you're talking to somebody that
doesn't understand what that means
what do you mean you know the bars on
the front of your shoulders not on your
back
okay and then i'm gonna have 335 pounds
on the bar at one point
and i'm gonna try to get uh three reps
and i'm gonna try to be as fast as i
possibly can
as fast as i possibly can so uh how
so walk me through what the goal is in
terms of um
you know i don't i don't really get how
the speed machines that we have in our
weight room work i know that my goals
get like over at 0.7
which is pretty fast so i'm gonna try to
hit that
and then i got um some calf things you
know got to look good in the uniform for
my wife
um and just a good stretching it's a
it's like just to make your body feel a
little better because
if you don't move the day after a game
yes you get pretty stiff and it's not
fun
interesting so 335 um
mike del tufo my my sound engineer yes
uh
says he's planked 145 before and we
thought like there's no way you plank
145 pounds
no he's referred to that as one plate of
45. so 335 is three
three plates of 35. yeah so it's not
even a hundred pounds that's a joke
right you can do that no no you mean 335
pounds
right george i do do me on that you guys
are funny
he literally said that when he played he
planks 145 we're like yeah right no it's
one plate of 45
is what he said that's nice come on man
you got to understand the lingua man no
it's not the way it works it's just not
the way it works
all right george thanks for the call uh
i love watching you ball out
and again it's not a fantasy football
thing you know how i feel about you
whatever you say i appreciate you guys
having me on
invite me back anytime love talking with
you boys right back at you thank you
thanks george that's george kittle
everybody right here in the rich housing
show
the friend of the program right there
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here